bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video siamo di nuovo su the
great war che la mappa di amnesia erano
rimasti che qualcuno mi ha sfondato la
porta pensava fosse tipo hulk spedendo
un secondo che qui mi arrivato un
messaggio pazienza
niente prima che avevano sfondato la
porta e non mi ricordo cioè non ho visto
chi era meno male
niente rimasti qui ok io chiudo perché
si sa mai
perfetto questa e una tanica di olio e
mi servirebbe è invece non la posso
usare fantastico no perché la lanterna
la lanterna si scarica abbastanza in
fretta quindi mi farebbe comodo ma no
per carità va beh torniamo indietro
perché non dovrebbe esserci più niente
da fare avevo lasciato una strada c'era
un bivio prima quindi devo tornare
indietro a vedere che cosa c'era
dall'altra parte allora non mi ricordo
assolutamente là dove sono arrivato ok
da lì perfetto quindi andiamo di qua
messo le stanze qui sono tutti qua oddio
cos'è un barattolo di vetro che è
fantastica no no non sembra esserci
nulla di sospetto a parte qualcosa che
mi ha sfondato la porta nel
nell'episodio precedente non c'è nulla
di strano per ora non vorrei tirarmela
ma paura che adesso possa diventare
pesante diciamo
l'ultima stanza ragazzi
o che cos'è questo all poi lo fitro
vitriol e dovrebbe essere tipo un acido
va beh io ho le forbici se prova ad
avvicinarsi quel colosso io le forbici
che poi non sono neanche forbici sono
presi nei ma non importa cosa devo far
agazzi perché ho trovato allora cosa un
barattolo di vetro contenitori vetro
volte mettiamoci l'acido non funziona
approdasse ok ok tutto chiaro può darsi
che debba andare qui ammetterlo qui
sotto per prendere l'olio e poi metterlo
sulla leva che nello scorso episodio non
funzionava allora ci provo però una
sospensione la valvola rifiuta di
muoversi ok e come cazzo facciamo
sfondo lavato mamma mia che genia
ragazzi fare le cose a caso funziona
ok vai non puoi usare oggetti in questo
modo è come lo vuoi che lo si scusa
certamente a terra sono un genio ragazzi
la vedo difficile se continuo così
allora barattolo di vetro con olio e
riempito lo re proprio allora adesso
dovrei andare devi tornare dove c'era la
leva perché dovrei riuscire a tirar l'ha
visto che era arrugginito mi serviva
l'olio qua chiuso perché mica go sempre
addosso se quello sfonda non che poi
basterebbe tirare la porta però va bene
ok
questa è chiusa cioè non si può tirare
bene
ok ha bisogno di più forza per muoversi
vai martello di thor da milato potenza
vai così fa vj ragazzi fa vj risolvere
tutti gli enigmi l'enigma più difficile
del mondo mettere dell'olio su una leva
per me ai ragazzi è una cosa impossibile
sono arrivato a tanto mi stupisco di me
stesso intanto si è creato un tornado
qua dentro hanno capito perché non mi
chiedete
comunque ora che ho attivato il
meccanismo dovrei riuscire ad aprire la
porta sempre che non ci sono brutte
sorprese mette torno indietro ma non
dovrebbe ok
qua c'è la porta che si apre
davanti intanto è rimasto di olio poco l
ok ragazzi ma ce la siamo presi molto
comoda ho paura di cosa andrò a trovare
non ho idea ma non importa la scala già
promette male ma non proseguiamo stesso
le ho io se scale qui fatte di ferro in
amnesia mi terrorizzano perché scendere
in questo modo cioè più in basso vai a
mio parere è peggio è posta filosofia
quindi di gioco che non sono dove l'ho
presa quasi gocciola tutto intanto il
centro pa radioattivo che farsi il bagno
fantastico
si dice che vuoi
[Musica]
rumori stranissimi c'è una porta o c'è
anche dell'altro olio che però non posso
prendere differenza dell'altro se questo
truciolato re non so che cosa mi può
sapere
porta chiusa c'è del sangue ma io devo
entrare dove c'è il sangue mi sembra più
su candela la posso prendere no non
posso proprio devo aprire quella porta
presumo debba mettere qualcosa qui sopra
forse un'altra candela non lo so noi
proseguiamo c'è c'è un osso perché c'è
un osso io prendo l'osso trofei o stop
indicami la strada e dimmi se libero
fammi sapere dai quarti il bilancio dato
cugino lo vedi che lì nell'angolo fammi
sapere tutto libera
grazie mi danno una mano perché sono mi
danno una mano loro ragazzi
ok osso ci sono pieni di ossa i ragazzi
poco sotto che culo c'è ios posto sempre
eletti perché nella storia principale di
amnesia c'era una botola e quindi da
quel dove la volta in avanti risposto
sempre però
cioè non ho mai non ci ho mai trovato
più niente sotto i letti tranne stavolta
mi andata bene ok
sarà una stanza bonus è semplicemente
per proseguire non so fatto qua c'è
qualcosa di sopra un altro letto penso
ok
totti togliti no no ok mi sto ricoprendo
sono un gene
la facciamo perfetto
no non esco non c'è dammi la scatola se
scatole non servono una minchia renditi
utile almeno farmina scalino marasso
letto se si toglie dalle palle niente o
devono per miccoli c'è verso ok siamo
usciti perfetto che serve sostanza una
candela allora ok perfetto allora adesso
devo tornare presumo dov'ero prima però
dato che è immenso sto posto
qualcos'altro può fare i nostri
escapista maledetta porta stiletti kek
accatasta eletti davanti alle porte
ragazzi probabilmente è stato lui in
questo caso ti sta bene mi fai perder
tempo dove sono finiti questi ragazzi sì
ma di giocare a labyrinth
quando
oddio oh cazzo cazzo
[Musica]
beh ragazzi falso allarme mi sono preso
un colpo per niente questa è stata
fantastica ragazzi non non me ne aspetto
no perché d'asta mappa non ha ancora
perso nessuno a parte quello che ha
sfondato la porta ma non si è visto nel
primo episodio non era ancora apparso
nessuno quindi non me l'aspettavo questa
sciarrino ok
praga non so dove è andato quello lì ma
non mi interessa io provo a vedere se ci
sta la fan della sea ha descritto aprire
la gabbia del cancello del santuario ed
è qualcosa a che fare con le candele ma
va
minchia avevo capito io ho capito io ho
bocca per chiunque
cosa devo fare spegne la sofia non
funziona non c'è comando vocale in
amnesia come faccio molto divertiti di
togliere trovato spacca le spacca le
proprie non ce l'ha quali non so se non
penso ci proprio si sa mai
mamma mia mamma mia un secchio d'acqua
mamma mia per me è già tanto ragazzi
magari non funziona tutto un file
infatti non funziona ci avrei scommesso
raga ma funziona sia aperto
non ci posso credere che ha funzionato
una mia idea io cos'è questo un cerchio
alchemico fullmetal alchemist io vado 18
perché c'è qualcosa ancora in giro non
voglio stare più qua
sento dei ruggiti e andiamo sempre più
in basso non promette bene è la madonna
che è mica un po più buio esistono cose
chiamate torce si appendono i muri
dovreste accenderle non devo fare tutto
io è una donna che eccessivamente buio
però vedo un gradino non voglio
utilizzare la faticosa qua si è aperta
non me l'aspettavo
oddio cos'è ducati 10
ho trovato dieci ducati preferivo
trovare una ducati
se per chi se ne intende diciamo però mi
vanno bene anche 10 ducati così cosa che
me ne faccio di una ducati in mezzo
castello non lo so mezzo a un castello
il mio italiano ragazzi fa paura
l'olio non risparmio perché tanto vedete
si come no non vedo io come ha fatto
vedere voi lo sapete nel racconto del
fatto che quello che vedo io a stento
voi non lo vedete perché youtube oscura
di parecchio il video c'è i video in
generale che essa porta è chiusa
sì non posso entrare perché qualcuno ha
sbarrato la porta comunque si apre verso
l'interno quindi non vedo l'utilità di
queste sbarre però non importa porta non
si può aprire qualche del sangue
promette bene quindi andiamo avanti
lì si è spenta la lanterna e non posso
più non funziona più il tasto dallan
terna perfetto che cazzo è successo non
vedo niente è tutto buio ma mi sto
muovendo
se mi sto muovendo ma sei pagato oddio
cos'è che è successo lo sono cosa mi
sono drogato cazzo so non posso perché
non mi si accenderà lante mi è finito
l'olio perché mi è finito l'olio mi
chiamavo lasciato da parte un casino
grazie grazie mille
oddio non vedo niente ragazzi ma ne ho
sentito una cosa che non mi piaceva se
ancora tuo asso no mi serve una sedia
come una misera seria può farvi da scudo
non entrare il potere da segnati fermerà
lo so
non entrato ragazzi c'è non è non è
entrato veramente
brava sedia bravo così si fa bahrami
porta ti porto con me perché promette
bene però paura ad uscirne si unisce
alla sedia
so che hai paura delle sedie l'ho visto
aiuto
oddio dio chiedono no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no potere del tavolo va
via va via io ti libero da questo corpo
io santo ma se n'è andato non ci posso
credere viso grazie mamma mia ragazzi da
adesso i tavoli e le sedie saranno i
miei alleati migliori grazie tavolo sei
tu il mio alleato lo so ok penso di
averlo devo trovargli un nome perché la
destina vantin amnesia anche nel 2 i
tavoli e le sedie saranno i miei alleati
e overuse da cosa che termine da nerd
però è vero mi hanno salvato la vita ben
due volte in 30 secondi cazzo come
faccio a sapere se 5 tipico dopo i denti
ma come ci sono arrivato qua ma me lo
spiegate
effettivamente il mostro non c'è più è
scomparso proprio non c'è traccia ma ci
sono entrato perfetto ok
trovate una chiave c'è un po di roba che
non sa che serve comunque
niente termino qui l'episodio perché
questo mi è bastato diciamo spero che
nel prossimo sia molto più tranquillo
anche se so già che non sarà così sarà
molto peggio per la pazienza se vi è
piaciuto video è stato mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che trovate nella
descrizione di ogni mio video niente
lasciate un commento se volete ci
vediamo ha proseguito bene ragazzi